disciplinary proceedings for will
smith's oscar slap have begun as chris
rock speaks out for the first time
welcome everybody to entertainment
tonight listen all eyes were on chris
last night as he kicked off his ego
death stand-up tour in boston we were
inside the venue where it was clear
everybody loves chris
[Applause]
how was your weekend
about what happened
so if you came
chris spoke on the subject for 53
seconds at the beginning of his set a
source tells e.t chris knew he had to
address the elephant in the room
[Applause]
e.t field producer darla murray was
inside the theater which was sold out it
was clear the crowd here was very much
team chris they greeted him with two
standing ovations as he took the stage
it took him several minutes to actually
quiet everybody down and get ready for
the show
[Applause]
he was genuinely touched by the crowd's
reaction he definitely seemed a little
shaken up but as the show went on we saw
the chris rock that everyone was
expecting to see
and we're getting our first look at what
jada was doing when things started going
off the rails in this now viral tick
tock video film from behind jada appears
to lean forward in laughter after the
slap as chris says this will smith just
smack
me
i saw chris and as soon as i walked up
to him the first thing he said was i'm
so sorry and i'm like why are you
apologizing he's like it was supposed to
be your night it was supposed you and
amy and regina you all were doing such a
great job i'm so sorry this is now going
to be about this and another wild video
just resurfaced before you lose your
head get all crazy and toss your hands
up this anti-violence psa that will
filmed in 1992 is going viral just think
the person that uses the head can always
defeat the person that's just trying to
use their hands
late yesterday the academy announced
will has been given 15 days notice of a
vote regarding his violations and
sanctions and has the opportunity to
provide a written response will's fate
could be decided at the board's next
meeting april 18th the academy also
stated will was asked to leave the
ceremony but two sources tell e.t that
will was never told point blank that he
needed to leave the oscar show instead
at one point it was suggested that he
should leave this morning oscar winner
whoopi goldberg who's on the academy's
board of governors speculated about the
terrible optics if will had been removed
from the dolby theater they come back
from break yeah
now if he's in
some sort of state and he's
struggling and they're trying to get him
out the door
and it's still on camera
and i'm just thankful that our segment
happened
before chaos i didn't like it i just
thought it was unfair i'm torn i've
known chris for years he's great i've
met will he's great you know the
comedian side of me wants to be with
chris